parte ve usando las unidades correctas
explica el significado de la integral
definida desde 0 a 40 de el valor
absoluto dvd t
dt en el contexto del problema aproxima
este valor de esta integral usando una
suma de riman por la derecha con los 4
sus intervalos indicados en la tabla
bien vamos a trabajar la primera parte
del problema esta de aquí usando las
unidades correctas explica el
significado de la integral definida y es
esta integral que tenemos aquí ahora
aquí tenemos a la velocidad y para la
velocidad es un vector ahora bien si no
estuviera este valor absoluto aquí
entonces sí estaríamos hablando del
desplazamiento entonces aquí tenemos el
valor absoluto de la velocidad que es la
rapidez que multiplica a un pequeño
cambio en el tiempo y entonces todo esto
nos va a dar la distancia total que ella
recorrió
así que vamos a escribirlo la integral
definida desde 0 a 40 del valor absoluto
dvd t esto
dt todo esto va a representar la
distancia total déjame escribir la
distancia total
que ella recorrió
esto de aquí es la distancia total que
ella recorrió en los 40 minutos
es la distancia total que ella recorrió
en los 40 minutos y ya con esto tenemos
la primera parte de este inciso b usando
las unidades correctas
bueno espera nos faltaron las unidades
déjame escribirlo las unidades
unidades
son metros
ok y ya con esto ahora sí tenemos la
primera parte usando las unidades
correctas explica el significado de la
integral definida esta que tenemos aquí
en el contexto del problema y después
dicen aproximan el valor de esta
integral usando una suma de riman por la
derecha con los 4 sus intervalos
indicados en la tabla estos 4 sub
intervalos y bueno para eso lo que voy a
hacer es traer la gráfica por acá que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado esta gráfica
que tengo aquí y vamos a trabajar con
ella para que te sea mucho más claro lo
que está sucediendo
recuerda no es consenso que hagas esto
en el examen a p pero yo lo quiero hacer
para ayudarte a entender un poco mejor
este problema pero regresando a esto que
tenemos aquí si recuerdas en el vídeo
pasado pusimos de color naranja los
valores de la velocidad según esta tabla
pero ahora quiero aplicarme en el valor
absoluto de la velocidad entonces esto
me va a quedar y lo voy a poner de color
verde
absoluto de este es este muy bien el
valor absoluto de este es este el valor
absoluto de este es este pero en este
caso el valor absoluto de menos 220 va a
ser algo positivo estás de acuerdo va a
ser más 220 entonces podemos ver aquí
que cuando el tiempo vale 24 vedete es
menos 220 eso quiere decir que está
trotando en dirección contraria pero no
vamos a tomar el valor absoluto de eso
entonces nos va a quedar lo siguiente el
valor absoluto de menos 220 en el tiempo
te iguala 24 me va a quedar algo más o
menos por aquí más o menos por aquí
entonces cuando te es 24 su rapidez será
de 220 porque va a tomar el valor del
valor absoluto de este de aquí y para
por último el valor absoluto de este es
este que tenemos aquí
entonces ojo no conocemos la función
rapidez pero supongo que la función
rapidez se verían más o menos así se
vería más o menos
algo más o menos así esta sería mi
función rapidez déjenme escribirlo esta
de aquí sería mi función valor absoluto
de t lo cual ya sabemos que es la
función rapidez y ahora lo que nosotros
queremos hacer es encontrar el área bajo
la curva de esta función rapidez lo que
queremos hacer es integrarlo y bueno si
lo integramos se verían más o menos así
ahora el problema y quiero que lo
observé es que no tenemos esta función
rapidez
no sabemos explícitamente cuál es esta
función y por lo tanto no podemos saber
el valor exacto de esta integral pero lo
que podemos hacer es aproximar el valor
de esta integral de aquí con una suma de
rima y en este caso va a ser una suma de
rimar por la derecha lo voy a poner con
este
va a ser una suma de rima por la derecha
y es que una suma de riman es
simplemente romper esta área que
teníamos acá abajo en rectángulos y
finalmente encontrar el área total de
esos rectángulos y bueno hay dos formas
de hacer eso porque él cada rectángulo
puede tener la altura de la frontera
izquierda o la frontera derecha pero en
este caso vamos a tomarnos una suma de
riman por la derecha lo que quiere decir
que cada uno de estos rectángulos va a
tener como altura el valor que toma la
función en el punto de la derecha en la
frontera derecha y ya que construimos
todos estos rectángulos con la altura
dada lo que vamos a hacer es aproximar
esta área utilizando el área de los
rectángulos entonces vamos a hacerlo si
/ esto en cuatro rectángulos porque
bueno observa que tenemos cuatro
intervalos el primer intervalo va a ir
del tiempo de igual a cero al tiempo de
igual a 12s
intervalo baile el tiempo de igualdad 12
el tiempo te iguala 20 el tercero va a
ir desde el tiempo de igual a 20 hasta
el tiempo de igual a 24 y el cuarto va a
ir desde el tiempo de igual a 24 hasta
el tiempo de igual a 40 tenemos cuatro
intervalos ahora bien si toda esta idea
de sumas de riman por la derecha o por
la izquierda
te parece completamente desconocida
entonces te encargo que vean los videos
y resueltas los ejercicios sobre este
tema en la canaca de mi bien vamos a
hacer los rectángulos el primer
rectángulo se va a ver más o menos así
tenemos una base desde cero hasta doce y
vamos a tomar la altura que nos da el
valor de 2 que es justo esta de aquí así
que mi rectángulo se va a ver más o
menos así tenemos como base el intervalo
de 0 a 12 y como altura el valor que
toma la función en el punto de la
derecha es decir en el tiempo de igual a
dous después tengo el segundo rectángulo
y se observa
se va a ir desde 12 hasta 20 desde 12
hasta 20 y este rectángulo va a tomar
como altura lo que valga la función en
el valor de t igual a 20 entonces se va
a ver más o menos así toma la altura del
punto de la derecha muy bien después
tengo el siguiente intervalo que me va a
definir el siguiente rectángulo y es de
20 a 24 de 20 a 24 y vamos a tomar el
valor que toma la función en el tiempo
de igual a 24 es decir el punto de la
derecha y se va a ver más o menos así
observa que estos rectángulos se ven un
poco irregulares pero está bien no
forzosamente deben de tener el mismo
ancho recuerda que es una aproximación y
por último el último rectángulo va a
tener como base desde 24 hasta 40 y va a
tomar la altura que toma la función en
el valor de 40 en el punto de la derecha
entonces se va a ver más
así ya tenemos aquí nuestros cuatro
rectángulos y entonces ya podemos decir
que la aproximación de esta integral
deja de escribirlo la aproximación de la
integral desde cero hasta 40 de el valor
absoluto de b dt ok esto
dt por una suma de riman por la derecha
va a ser bueno la suma del área de cada
uno de estos rectángulos entonces
podemos escribir que esto va a ser
aproximadamente y primero tengo este
cambio en el tiempo que va a ser de 0
hasta 12 lo cual es un cambio en el
tiempo de 12 y lo vamos a multiplicar
por la altura de el valor del lado
derecho que es el valor de 12 lo cual es
200 entonces lo voy a multiplicar por
200 muy bien ya esto le voy a sumar la
segunda área
qué es la diferencia entre 20 y 12 bueno
hay de diferencia 8 minutos 8 que
multiplica y aquí tengo que la altura
del punto de la derecha es el valor que
toma la función de dt en 20 y b de 20 es
240 entonces a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por 240 y después le voy a sumar y ahora
me voy a aplicar en el siguiente cambio
en el tiempo que es de 20 a 24 y bueno
20 para 24 es 44 que multiplica a el
valor que toma la función en el punto de
la derecha que es de 24 o bueno espera
es el valor absoluto debe de 24 recuerda
que nos estamos tomando el valor
absoluto de cada uno de estos
entonces me va a quedar 4 x 220 ya esto
le voy a sumar el último cambio en el
tiempo que es de 40 a 24 de 40 a 24 lo
cual es 16
6 ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por el
valor absoluto del valor que toma la
función en 40 en 40 tomamos el valor de
150 el valor absoluto de 150 así que lo
voy a poner aquí y lo quiero ser muy
claro con esto esto de aquí es una
aproximación es la aproximación de la
suma del área de este rectángulo lo cual
es bueno tiene una base de 12 de 12
minutos y lo multiplicamos por la altura
que en este caso es el valor absoluto
del valor que toma el punto de la
derecha que es 200 ya esto le sumamos
bueno el área de este rectángulo que es
8 x 240 ya eso le sumamos el área de
este rectángulo que es 4 x 220 ya esto
le sumamos el área de este rectángulo
que es 16 por 150 me estoy tomando una
aproximación y ahora si esto va a ser
aproximadamente cuánto bueno pues esto
lo podemos hacer a mano 12 x 200 es lo
mismo que 2400 muy bien
y después tengo 8 x 240 bueno 8 x 40 es
320 8 x 203 1600 entonces me va a quedar
1920 ya esto le voy a sumar 4 x 220 eso
es 880 y por último le voy a sumar 16
por ciento 50 bueno espera 15 por 15 es
225 y si el aumento este 0 me va a
quedar 2 mil 225 más una vez 150 bueno
esto es lo mismo que 2 mil 250 más 150
es 2400 otra vez 2400 y si ahora me tomo
la suma de todo esto vamos a hacerlo
aquí tengo 2400 2.400 a esto le sumó
1920 1920 a esto le sumó 880
a esto le sumó 2400 otra vez 2400
entonces me va a quedar lo siguiente 08
y 2 son 10 y llevo una y tengo 5 y 9 es
14 y 8 es 22 y 4 es 26 entonces 26 y
llevo 2 déjame ver si lo hice bien 9 y 1
son 10 14 22 26 de lujo y después me
queda 2 467 7.600 entonces déjame
notarlo esto es igual a 7.600 y bueno
como estamos hablando de la distancia
total sus unidades son los
y ya está este es mi resultado y tal vez
estés tentado a decir bueno estamos
buscando un área que el área no se mide
en metros cuadrados pero ten cuidado
recuerda que nos estamos fijando en el
área abajo de esta curva de la función
rapidez
entonces si piensas en unidades bueno
pues observa que aquí tenemos 12 minutos
12 minutos y aquí esta altura de aquí va
a tomar el valor de 200 de 200 metros
sobre minuto sobre minuto así que los
minutos se cancelarían y me quedaría
simplemente metros no metros cuadrados
sino metros y ya con esto acabamos este
inciso b